kämpfen klatschen fürs klima aber wer
macht sich laut für freunde von
kraftfahrzeugen mit betonung auf kraft
er hier christopher grau und weitere
autofans mit einer facebook-gruppe
fridays von hubraum daraus wurde wider
willen ein forum für hetze haas vor
allem auf umweltaktivistin greta
thunberg beispiele was kostet eigentlich
so ein auftragsmord
das passiert wenn die eltern geschwister
sind also mich würde nicht wundern wenn
die so viel hass kassiert dass sie einer
irgendwann ausknipst waren wir alle
erschüttert haben gesagt leute das geht
komplett in die falsche richtung wir
haben gar keinen bock auf irgendwelchen
rechtspopulismus und auch die us-post
gegen greta gehen gar nicht das ist ein
16-jähriges mädchen haben wir dich
gemacht sofort auch alice seidel von der
afg verwies auf das forum und greta
thunberg auch mit emotionen gegenüber
ihren gegnern ihr ton nicht vulgär aber
hart sie rät ihren anhängern
verschwendet nicht eure zeit denen noch
irgendwie beachtung zu geben alles wird
anders
ob sie es mögen oder nicht eingetrübt
das klima ein riss in der kommunikation
woher kommen die emotionen
[Musik]
die wut kommt glaube ich aus angst wenn
sich menschen bedroht fühlen dann
reagieren manche mit aggressionen und
bedroht fühlen sich einige von den
demonstrierenden schülern die wirklich
angst um ihre zukunft haben bedroht
fühlen sich aber auch die leute die
merken mist ich bin ja selber
verantwortlich für den klimawandel
vielleicht kann ich meinen lebenswandel
nicht so weiterspielen wie bisher nie
zueinander finden zu hören die anliegen
hören so der rat
man muss fragen was eigentlich das
bedürfnis dahinter ein suv zu fahren ein
auto zu haben
meinetwegen freiheit mein finger ein
statussymbol zu haben dass diese
bedürfnisse können auch anders
befriedigt werden also wenn es
alternativen gibt und wir über
alternativen sprechen und mehr über
lösungen sprechen
ich glaube dass wir dann auch aus dieser
spirale der gegenseitige beschimpfung
rauskommen am umgang miteinander
arbeiten konstruktiv nicht radikal
fordert auch christopher grau auch wenn
es bald eine zukunft mit weniger hubraum
geben könnte